this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
on today's episode he's going to be
checking out the weaponry from the last
of us part
two now this this ammunition is made out
of
explosive and blades that's not
that's not how this works as this as the
mean goes if there are any other games
guns or mechanics that you guys want to
see jonathan break down let us know in
the comment section below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one and if you'd like to help
out the royal armouries museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
something wrong boy
well i've already seen some interesting
gameplay here so we've got a
sort of parallel reality version of a
of a beretta i think i saw it's called a
nicotero i don't know if that's an
oblique reference to greg
nicotero or not but um there are
berettas with rounded trigger guards but
not in the same configuration
so but it's pretty close improvised
suppressors as we've covered on the
channel before do work
the only real way in which they're less
efficient than
a properly designed sound suppressor is
that they only work
equivalently for one shot sooner
especially a plastic water bottle
as soon as the massive overpressure of a
muzzle blast
and the bullet exiting the plastic
happens that bottle is
literally trash something that would
affect you in real life that doesn't
hear
is the the large diameter of these
things
totally ruins your side picture but
we're a third person game here so we get
the reticle
over the shoulder without the
obstruction of the silencer the whole
feel is
for me so far is very much realistic
feel
but like a horror movie so the effects
of bullets hitting people are greatly
exaggerated but that's
that's absolutely standard in video
games in general and those within the
horror genre especially
so a nine millimeter bullet from a from
a beretta should not explode the back of
somebody's head
like it does at 30 meters whatever that
is but uh
artistic license
i've got to say having been a bit
nitpicky about
the beretta and the silencer i am really
enjoying
the scrappiness of the gunfights
they feel very realistic and there's a
realistic detail in the revolver
reload that we see there which is maybe
too realistic
if the idea here is that these the
protagonists are
not really trained so somebody with with
minimal training and a revolver
that they found lying around and this is
incidentally
roughly what the last of us two revolver
is based on this is a taurus 66.
so the reload thing i'm talking about is
um press the catch and open the cylinder
and you use the fingers to hold the
cylinder out of the gun
to load the rounds and that's what we
see the character doing there
now that's something that someone might
have taught her she might have figured
out for herself
but that that is one of the preferred
techniques for
reloading a revolver with a swing out
cylinder because otherwise
you flip it out like that to the side
and it's a bit awkward
and um the the the recoil the amount
that the weapon is moving in the
character's hands again i think is
realistic for the sort of character
that is in the game i like the fact that
there's an element of
fortune over where your bullets are
gonna go which hopefully isn't too
frustrating in terms of gameplay
okay this is an interesting choice i use
the word interesting
a lot but in this case it's because it
is a single shot uber powerful
handgun and it is sort of based on a
thompson
center contender which is actually a
well i believe they're used for hunting
but um
it was developed as the name would imply
for competition
shooting now they come in various shapes
and sizes
i've gone for a larger one this is in
the same caliber as in the game however
this is a 4570
which is big so it's intuitively
uh makes some sense that it's doing
clearly a lot of damage to the enemies
in the game
too much damage though i mean even even
a 45-70
bullet of significant mass and velocity
cannot remove somebody's arm
which we saw at one point so we're
actually seeing some
field expedient ammunition manufacturer
as well
now this this ammunition is made out of
explosive and blades that's not
that's not how this works as this as the
meme goes lead
funnily enough is is the best material
to make bullets out of certainly in
terms of what you could find lying
around
you would not be wanting to load your
cases with
explosive however gunpowder propellant
of whatever sort has a very specific
burn rate for whatever application it is
you're loading for and you do not want
to be putting
explosive into a cartridge case because
explosive
detonates instantly effect relative to
powder which
burns in a controlled way
this is another not quite real type of
shotgun
it's pretty close to the remington 870.
really nicely
realized sound design whole game seems
to be really very good
the sort of feel of the the shotgun
blast going off
you you get just watching it you get the
sense of the power of this thing and
uh 12 12 12k shotguns are really
powerful
close range weapons no no two ways
around it but the thing that distracted
me
uh from all of that was the sling
because historically
weapons in game either appear out of the
workforce and i mean really historically
at this point
appear out of nowhere or they stick to
your back
magically with some space magnets or
something
games that mod that model slings and
games that implement slings as the
actual way that you sling the weapon are
very huge between even there i didn't
see a weapon get
slung but the way the sling is hanging
off that shotgun is just
for me it's kind of they've actually
nailed the physics of how a sling hangs
from the gun
so that was cool
so we've got another shotgun this is a a
fairly conventional trap or skeet
shotgun over and under configuration
break open such as you'd find pretty
much anywhere in the world actually
again very nice implementation of it in
terms of the
the report of the of the thing going off
we and then we see some
some interesting ammunition crafting
where we're making
uh incendiary ammunition to take on the
creatures
uh which which is pretty effective on uh
on the normal people as well as we see
there
it's ever so slightly off looking as a
as a model
it doesn't quite look like a real world
gun
just in the way it's modeled it looks a
bit too chunky and melty
a bit too robust and it has some very
odd porting in the bar well not very odd
but odd for the sort of shotgun that it
is
porting in the two barrels and um as
ever
with a double barrel shotgun in any game
it gives you a lot of power
but only two shots and then that moment
of panic as you try to reload it
the choice of rifle is unusual
unusual for a for a third personal first
person shooter in that
it's a civilian oriented
design so this is based on the molot uh
vapor
vapor clearly a russian design and it's
kalashnikov derived but it is configured
as a
sporting hunting rifle and i think that
i think that
is almost that's clearly deliberate the
developers have chosen something that
fits the setting so something that you
found lying around
often with with games and other media
you're finding lying around weapons that
you wouldn't necessarily
depending which country depending on
which part of which country so i think
that's the idea is that this is this is
a
sporting rifle that you've come across
that happens to be capable enough to use
as a combat weapon in a pinch the weird
there's a at one point the thing is
firing in a
burst mode which i gather is to do with
an upgrade
the the the normal ak type selector on
the side is replaced by one with some
red bits on it and is able to fire
burst so you'll effectively converting a
self-loading only rifle to
a burst fire rifle which would is rather
more difficult to do
than i think is being depicted in the
game
certainly to a controlled burst
mechanism and actually where
weapons like this are are partly
redesigned
as sporting weapons deliberately to
avoid them being convertible
to automatically burst fire it has a
realistic feel to it that they've made
this decision
but the real world believability of that
is pretty low actually
so
so the direct contrast to the vepr
hunting rifle
being something that you might find in a
sort of household or farm setting or
something
is this which is a sig mpx
submachine gun pretty close pretty close
to the uh real real weapon
uh which we haven't got one of yet but
um i have had hands on it before
the rate of fire in the game is very
slow
it almost feels a bit stereotypical
third person shoot for smg
in in terms of a bit of a chugging rate
of fire but the real thing
uh rattles away at eight to 900 rounds
per minute
so i'm not sure that's quite accurate i
think the
the sound suppressor maybe it's just um
the way it sounded just then but that
seemed to be a bit more realistic than
than the pistols oppressed i'm guessing
that this is something you find
in context uh some sort of security
courses or something or using it so
we've it's a
quite an eclectic range of weapons that
they've gone for uh but it it gives a
lot of variety a lot of
they're almost all pretty distinct from
each other in contrast to the
the sort of full realism military
shooter where
it's almost like more realistic you get
more sailing where your weapons get
we've got a lot of
interesting variety here
right well i hope you enjoyed that one i
certainly did uh
that's a franchise that i've yet to get
into
and um i'm all more interested to do so
now that i've seen the way
that the weapons are represented if
you'd like to give us a bit of support
here at the royal armouries museum we've
got links in the description for that
otherwise both ways i'll see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you